it's good to wear sunscreen year round
but it is really the time of year for
sunscreen right now you may have heard
FDA warnings about chemical sunscreens
which can cause skin irritation and
other issues that's why it's best to use
a mineral sunscreen like the one by
Ginger armor it is just as effective
much safer and you'll save 15 percent
with the code Pacman the link is down
below
I want to start with something kind of
funny today Steve Ducey is one of the
three hosts of The Fox News Morning Show
Fox and Friends and over the last 6 to
12 months occasionally Steve Ducey has
had these strange moments of clarity
where he will interject a fact or an
actually sort of interesting analysis
about a political situation usually his
hosts look kind of confused about the
fact that he's rather than
propagandizing just saying something
that's uncontroversially true and of
course we're left to speculate about
what's going on is it ducey's uh sort of
private little way of rebelling against
the disinformation spread on Fox and
Friends or is it just that he stumbled
across a fact which happens sometimes
very sporadically on Fox News who knows
these clips are from the decoding Fox
News Twitter account who does a really
good job in this clip talking about most
of these clips are related to the 2024
Republican primary which is increasingly
an interesting topic on Fox News because
Fox News is sort of trying to figure out
what is our position going to be be are
we going to be overtly pro-trump or are
we going to be subtly pro-trump or are
we going to be subtly anti-trump in the
sense that we will not talk about Trump
the most or will we choose a particular
candidate other than Trump like DeSantis
or others to attach ourselves to and try
to really promote that candidate it's
not clear the direction Fox News will go
yet but
here is Steve Ducey uh stating something
I talked about on the Wednesday show
which is when you look at polling in May
or June of the year before the primary
it's very often not representative of
who ultimately wins and Steve Ducey
actually doing that analysis which is a
smart analysis and it's an appropriate
one that we should be doing which has
not been done on Fox News take a look
and his uh his co-hosts look visibly
confused and the first votes in the
caucuses aren't going to be until uh
July or rather January
she said in May of 20 2007 Romney McCain
and Rudy were all in the top three and
Mike Huckabee was at zero percent but
Mike Huckabee went on to win the Iowa
caucuses and then in May 2015
it the top three were Walker Rubio and
Huckabee and Cruz and Trump who finished
one and two were not even at 10 this is
all true so so much can happen in Iowa
and one of the great things said uh okay
so this is absolutely correct and the
message here is a very simple message
the fact that Trump is so far ahead
today doesn't guarantee that Trump will
be the eventual Republican nominee now
it's great that Steve Ducey is
introducing some evidence into this
historical evidence that I also
introduced his data was specifically
from Iowa where I was talking more
generally at the same time it just so
happens that this time around the
circumstances are particularly uh
unprecedented in the sense that yes the
leader at this point in time isn't
always the eventual nominee but the
leader at this point in time also isn't
usually a former president and that is
what we have right now so great for
Steve Ducey to bring these things up the
two people who said alongside him don't
seem to know one way or the other what's
going on here's another example Steve
Ducey points out correctly
that DeSantis argument that he could
serve eight years if he wins in 2024
whereas Trump would immediately be a
lame duck is absolutely true and Steve
Ducey mentions that as well as a reason
that maybe Republicans do want to
consider someone other than Trump who
would on day one be a lame duck
interesting I'm not avoiding the punch
I'll address it but it's not going to be
my focus and by the way he's big into
eight years I'm gonna need more than
four years to fix this Donald Trump can
only do four right I need eight I'll get
you eight if you get me four I'll get
another four if you elect Donald Trump
he can't give you another four so that's
a legitimate uh tactic without
alienating the base you know the famous
thing is whoever beats Donald Trump you
have to beat him and get his voters if
you beat him and lose his voters you
can't win but and Brian you make the
point that we were talking about last
week if Ron DeSantis wins he get he can
be he can serve for two terms but by the
Constitution Donald Trump who's already
served one term can only do another so
on on his first day he would be a lame
duck and that is one of the
considerations big donors have and the
worry from a lot of big donors is not
only does if Donald Trump won the
Primary it's a real good chance he would
lose the White House but also lose the
house and that's one of the problems but
listen I mean it's a pretty good
analysis from Steve Ducey I have to say
It's actually kind of like grounded in
reality I have absolutely no idea
whether this is the sort of thing that
the Fox News audience even pays
attention to when they watch Fox and
Friends Fox and Friends is very much the
type of show that you kind of have on in
the background while you're I don't know
making breakfast or whatever whatever
Fox News Watchers do in the morning I
don't know that it's really getting
through to anyone and I don't even know
that Ducey is doing this specifically to
push people away from Trump and towards
Ron DeSantis but it is certainly a very
very interesting thing that we are
seeing also interesting is that some of
the fox hosts aren't thrilled with
Trump's attacks on his own former press
secretary Kaylee mcinanny let's talk
about that next on the Wednesday show I
showed you a truth social post truth
essential yeah of Donald Trump attacking
his own former press secretary Kaylee
mcineny saying that she was wrong about
some of the polling numbers and she's
milk toast and Trump misspelled milk
toast and just attacking his own former
staffers and I told you about all of the
reasons that making it a regular thing
when he's trying to build the staff and
campaign for president attacking former
staffers may not be a good idea Brian
kilmead who is another of the hosts on
Fox and Friends says that it was insane
for Donald Trump to go after Kaylee
mcinanny remember that Kaylee mcinanny
is now a co-worker of Brian Kilmeade she
is a Fox News employee kill me doesn't
think this is a good idea for Trump take
a look he flies off the handle for
example for example talking Kaylee
mcanini is insane she's one of the best
press secretaries ever Dana Perino as as
Ari Fleischer watching too I'm just
saying she was fantastic but she's she's
an analyst now she doesn't work for any
campaign yeah so Brian Kilmeade the most
important thing Kaylee mcinerney was not
the best press secretary ever maybe she
was like the most dishonest maybe the
one who told the most Lies per minute
during press briefing she was not the
best press secretary ever but he is
accurately pointing out that it is
insane for Trump to go after Kaylee
mcinanny and by the way if you believe
if Trump does believe that his final
press secretary Kaylee mcinerney was the
best one and did a good job I don't know
why you would want to alienate her this
early on in a Republican primary
campaign when not only might it be
useful to you to have her on your side
if maybe she decides hey I want to talk
about how great Trump is or whatever the
case may be and maybe you would try to
call on her again for some kind of help
in the campaign or staff or it just
seems so uh short-sighted and the
typical narcissism of Trump to be
attacking her because she read poll
numbers that Trump didn't like one other
really really really funny thing from
this episode of fox and friends a Fox
News correspondent referred to Ron
DeSantis as Ron Des Sanctus on air which
is Trump's nickname for him I don't know
why I found this so funny but something
about it is Tuesday in New Hampshire and
of course Iowa is where everybody starts
that's why Des Sanctus and Trump are
there this week we'll see if Christy
doubles back to go there soon my guess
is he will that is that that is just
pure comedy the reporter referring to
him as the next thing you know they'll
be saying Ron de sanctimonious or even
Rob Des sanctimonious so I I'm very
interested in this
um I guess we would call it like the Fox
News factor in the Republican primary
because as we've said before
it's not that millions and millions and
millions of people are watching Fox News
all the time such that fox instantly
shifts public opinion in something like
a Republican primary but we have to
admit that Fox News has certainly set
itself up to be an agenda Setter when it
comes to the campaigns uh of Republican
candidates and political campaigns in
general and so whatever approach starts
on Fox first thing in the morning with
Fox and Friends it is more influential
than the audience numbers would suggest
is I think the way I would put it and as
a frame of reference we have right now a
situation where it's Trump 53 in the
primary de Sanctus 22 Nikki Haley in
third place at about four and a half
Mike Pence who's officially launching
next week just under four Vivek
ramaswamy at three or under three Tim
Scott's got 1.6 you know it kind of goes
down from there Chris Christie who will
also be announcing on Tuesday pulling a
very anemic one percent he's a one
percenter right now not in the way that
I think he wants to be and so this is
going to be a weird primary for sure I
think it will get significantly more
compelling with the entrance of Christy
and Pence and we will be watching all of
it we have a fantastic friday show for
you today I'm glad you're with us make
sure you're signed up on our website at
joinpakman.com we'll take a quick break
then we'll hear from some of you via
Discord and then the program will
continue
it is Springtime it's getting warm we
are all spending more time outside many
sunscreens contain elements that the FDA
has warned about oxybenzone Ava benzone
homo sailate and others these are
absorbed into your bloodstream they can
irritate sensitive skin they can be
hormone disruptors I just stay away from
them and I use mineral sunscreens I do
the same when I put sunscreen on my baby
daughter and our sponsor Ginger armor
makes the world's thinnest 100 mineral
sunscreen it works for all skin types
not just gingers as the name might
suggest it rubs in clear on all skin
tones feels like nothing is on with SPF
50 plus protection Ginger armor also
acts as a plant-based moisturizer with
21 simple gentle ingredients from plants
and minerals it's good for you it's good
for the planet it's more affordable than
other sunscreens with similar quality
ingredients I also love that it's a
small business made in the U.S and they
donate one percent of all sales to the
one percent for the planet charity go to
gingerarmor.com use code Pacman for 15
off the link is down below
the David pakman show continues to
depend on the support of our viewers and
our listeners to do what we do we're not
the daily wire we don't have millionaire
and potentially billionaire supporters
just throwing money at us we do depend
on folks who listen to the podcast or
watch clips on YouTube or tick tocks or
whatever the case may be you can sign up
at joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now and uh you of course
get access not only to the bonus show
every weekday but also commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
let's go to the Discord phone lines and
hear from some of the folks in our
audience we do this on the Friday show
you can find our Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord that is the place for it let's
start today with Bert from New Jersey
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hey David hear me okay yes I can
okay
uh two questions uh comes from the Trump
Town Hall a couple weeks ago yes CNN
more
curious about your opinion
um my opinion is there's been a lot of
uh pushback from the CNN people that you
know how dare you give this guy a
platform you know
um basically empowering him
you know most of the time you hear a
trump interview he's talking to Sean
Hannity he's talking to Tucker Carlson
it's like a uh you know Kim Jong-un
being interviewed by North Korean State
media right you're not getting any real
substance wait look at it we were able
to see him actually push for once right
and he had to actually like respond to
same election was stolen and and you
know saying he can wave his hand and uh
declassify documents right so like for
me there was value and seeing him having
to actually be confronted with this
stuff and like talk about it
um left me feeling like like to see it
again you know like here's if you
thought the same or if you got the same
reaction out of that yeah I mean here's
the thing in principle I agree with you
and there was some pushback the problem
is and you know Caitlin Collins who
hosted it has gotten a lot of the
criticism I don't know that any single
person
Trump lies so much that it's a bigger
task than any one person can handle to
actually do justice to what should be
the amount of pushback that he should be
getting it's it's it's an impossible
position to be in and so while on the
one hand you're right he was quote
confronted with the reality that nobody
nobody in any kind of position of
authority has found any wrongdoing with
2020 or whatever the case may be it
really wasn't enough and his supporters
saw it and they were emboldened by how
he wasn't going to submit to CNN and
whatever so I I don't know if it really
did any more good than it did harm that
being said CNN has every right to do
town halls with you know they're doing
one with Nikki Haley they're doing one
with Pence even though Pence hasn't
announced like it's not that CNN
shouldn't be doing these events it's
just really hard to do it justice and do
it responsibly
right
yeah no that's totally fair totally fair
um and the other thing I was I was gonna
ask you too is uh for yourself as you're
sitting there watching this right do you
ever feel like kind of conflicted
because on one side you know you the
man's uh policy is to you repulsive
everything about him is terrible but at
the same time he gives you material
right and it's like it's exciting to
talk about and it's it's uh gives you
like uh
so much spark right so do you ever feel
yourself not I'm not gonna say rooting
for him but like as much as you hate him
part of his like well like you know this
is great he's back we can talk about all
these things out is that you ever get
that feeling I don't get the grade he's
back thing I mean here here's the thing
I have no controller say over whether
Trump's a candidate I don't and I have
no controller say whether corporate
media gives the guy attention I do a
show there are always things happening
in this country there will always be
things to talk about and so is Trump
entertaining in a very kind of
disturbing way where you laugh to avoid
crying absolutely do I I don't feel
conflicted because I have absolutely no
involvement in the fact that this guy is
running again and he has tens of
millions of supporters so I 100 agree
with what you're saying but I don't I
don't have any kind of internal conflict
no
all right Bert from Jersey thank you
very much great to hear from you why
don't we go next to Nicole from Utah
Nicole from Utah welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
hi David can you hear me yes I can
okay I want your thoughts on just how
many people are entering the Republican
primary race and how they are all saying
the same things about former president
Trump I know and but and they're not
really saying much right I mean is that
sort of part of your point
yes yeah I think that there are a couple
different things going on
it's not a crazy idea to think to
yourself Trump's been arrested once he
may get arrested again he may get
arrested a third time at least and
that's just by this September
he may legitimately struggle to stay in
this race because he will be so tied up
in court and so I want to be there as an
alternative if indeed Trump who has a
commanding lead is unable to run in a
way that makes sense the problem is and
so part of this is if I want to be there
to pick up Trump's supporters I can't be
the one Republican who's running
who is going to do the biggest
criticisms of trump so this is why Tim
Scott and Nikki Haley and whoever else
will talk about it time for a change or
a different generation or whatever but
they won't really go after him the
unfortunate reality for them is that if
you're polling one two three four five
and DeSantis is at 20 something if
indeed Trump has that issue that pushes
him out of the race a lot of that
support will almost certainly go to
DeSantis who is the most viable in the
context of the general election and also
already has the most support and is
using the exact same strategy so far yes
DeSantis has sort of gone after Trump a
little bit but he said he would pardon
him and he's talking more about Joe
Biden than he is about Trump so I think
it's a deliberate strategy from all of
them saying listen let me let me be
around in case Trump collapses but
they're not generating any path to the
nomination for themselves they're sort
of waiting around for one to be handed
to them I don't think it's going to work
I agree with you
all right Nicole from Utah thank you
thanks for having me all right there
goes Nicole let's go next
to Thai
from Iowa Thai from Iowa
hello David can you hear me yes I can
okay so I just wanted to bring this up
because there's just something I kind of
notice
um that uh and I feel like it's it's
usually with either figures that have
passed away like people that have passed
away or it's like a famous movie or
something like that or a book but
I've I've noticed a bunch of people so
for instance you know how George Orwell
is someone that that people on the right
seem to really really love
they really just talk about things being
orwellian in the sense of 1984 big
brother or government surveillance
government overreach but I don't know
that they love Orwell many of them don't
even really know what Orwell wrote To be
honest yeah I know but I just I mean I
guess I just kind of like I just
remember seeing someone on the Twitter
bio that was like a trump page and it
said Orwell was right no I mean I think
what we can say is they like referencing
things being orwellian even if they
don't really understand them that I
would agree with
yeah but it's just weird because Orwell
was a socialist yes and he was an
anti-fascist and all this other stuff he
wouldn't here like if if they um think
Biden's a socialist they would think
they would they would just like blush if
they saw someone like Orwell as
president no that's absolutely true and
I think that comes through much more in
Animal Farm which is another Orwell book
more than it does in 1984. the the sort
of socialist ideas I mean listen you
have to understand this right-wing
movement is a movement that has been
anti-intellectual pseudo-intellectual uh
skeptical of or even hostile to deep
thinking and higher education for a long
time now and so the fact that they even
mention Orwell is sort of remarkable but
they know very very little if you say
Hey you know can you kind of compare and
contrast Orwell's Vision in 84 versus
Aldous huxley's Vision in Brave New
World and which do you think applies
more you these aren't folks who are able
to engage in on that they've just they
heard orwellian and now they've started
using the term but I don't really think
these are serious people
yeah and then like another one is the
Matrix is another one so like with the
red pill and all this other stuff and if
there's even a going on thing for follow
the White Rabbit and the people that
made the The Matrix are two transgender
sisters yeah
yeah no the identity thing is funny but
listen they don't care that it's just
the like like I said I wouldn't read
that much into it because these truly
aren't serious people we need to get
around them to make progress that's the
unfortunate reality
yeah that makes sense all right Thai
from Iowa thank you for the call
thank you for taking my call David all
right there it goes Ty just a reminder
that if you want to get on your nickname
should be name and location or location
and name some combination of that for
example Evan from Las Vegas Evan from
Las Vegas welcome to the program
thank you can you hear me okay yes I can
thanks for taking my call I had a
question just I feel like when Trump
first kind of rose to power in 2015 it
felt like it was going to be like a
crazy moment in history that we would
look back on and kind of laugh and now
that's really become the base of the
Republican party this misinformation and
kind of willful ignorance do you see
that like changing or like how will we
look back on this time in history listen
I the question of how will we look back
on this time in history is one of those
that you ask a hundred people you'll get
a hundred different answers nobody has
any clue you know imagining how the
future will retrospectively I I could
give you some guess but I really have no
idea My Hope Is My Hope Is that Maga
trumpism will die with Trump and by that
I don't mean Trump's literal death
necessarily but the death of Trump's
political career because the truth is if
Trump doesn't get the nomination next
year and certainly if Trump loses the
election next year I think it's
completely over for Trump that will be
the end of trump and then we will have
to see what happens to Mega trumpism
does it get rejected by the Republican
Party does it take over the Republican
party or does it get integrated into the
Republican Party sort of like the way
tea party ideology uh was integrated My
Hope Is that Maga trumpism dies with the
death of Trump's political career be it
in 20 in November of 24 or in January of
29 when the next president would be
inaugurated and that at that point we
get back to something being a marginally
more sane Republican party and that
history will look at it as an aberration
that's my hope I don't know that that's
the way it's going to go
yeah I definitely definitely share that
hope
um I had one other brief question I
heard you mention recently that you're
going to be in Santa Cruz California
which is my alma mater can I ask what
you're up to there oh yeah I'm going out
there for a wedding and it's the Santa
Cruz area it's not it's not actually
Santa Cruz but it's the Santa Cruz area
oh okay I say I wasn't sure if you're
maybe doing a speaking engagement at the
University or something like that no no
no but so what's the is downtown Santa
Cruz worth checking out I was doing some
street view sort of but it's it's sort
of unclear to me what's going on down
there
yeah you know I haven't been I've been
like in the last probably a year or two
and I I love it it's just kind of like a
chill Beach town you know there's some
some cool record stores you know
breweries and uh if you want to get a
bagel there's this place called The
Bagelry that has pretty good bagels and
locks I know you're a fan yeah yeah and
is the is the salmon co cold smoked do
you know
uh you know I I don't I don't know that
but I'll see if I can make a call and
find out yeah yeah you know I'm a I'm a
Jewish ethnicity so I I like to think I
have decent standards for for my Nova
locks and uh I think it's decent are you
for scallions or chives in cream cheese
uh I I could go either way I guess if I
had to pick I'd probably go chives oh
dear God okay all right I'm Gonna Let
You Go all right oh no I'm scallion all
the way all right all right thank you no
I'll report back about Santa Cruz
cool all right take care there we go
folks big time Big Time stuff let's take
a very quick break don't hang up because
we're going right back to the phones in
a moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
let's hear from a few more people folks
who are waiting to chat you can use our
Discord
davidpackman.com
Discord why don't we go next to Seth
from Nebraska Seth from Nebraska welcome
to the David packman show what's on your
mind today
um hi David uh first time caller if you
can hear me I can hear you fine
awesome
um so I had a question my wife and I
were having a discussion actually last
night she is fearful of the future
um when it comes to you know like
Republicans and these policies that
they're
passing is you know they're just not
popular but they keep getting through
and I'm a little bit more optimistic
like
boomers are essentially dying off and
we're zenials and I think Millennials
and gen Z are like the largest voting
block now yeah I just wanted to know
kind of your opinion on
if
I don't see that this is sustainable for
the Republicans to just you know push
through all these unpopular ideas
um but you know like I said my wife is
fearful that it's just gonna keep
happening and you know our rights are
going to get you know diminished and
democracy is failing and all that I just
kind of wanted to know your thoughts
well so here's the thing
um let's deal with the The Fear Part
first okay
um one of the
one of the realities is that in the
United States if you live in
Massachusetts Connecticut Minnesota New
Hampshire New Jersey Colorado
the standard of living is measured by
the HDI human development index is very
similar to being in Switzerland Norway
Iceland Hong Kong you know the places
with the highest overall standards of
living with that metric human
development index in those States
regardless of what Republicans do in
Louisiana and regardless of what a
president does to some degree right at
the federal level you can start to
impact states
life on average is going to remain very
good
in the blue states with very high
standard of living and again in order by
HDI it's Massachusetts Connecticut
Minnesota New Hampshire Jersey Colorado
Washington DC Hawaii okay
in other states it's not going to be so
good like so I see that you're calling
for example from Nebraska Nebraska in
terms of HDI I think is kind of like
right in the middle I'm looking at it
um right now it's like it's not terrible
it's not actually Nebraska's okay
Nebraska's 13th in the country so
unfortunately what happens is when you
have democratic presidents and
Democratic houses and senates
things get a little bit better for
everyone and then when you have
Republican presidents and Republican
Governors Etc things get a little worse
for everyone but they get particularly
worse for a lot of these red states that
don't have their own protections already
built in and so sadly listen things can
get bad everywhere there's no question
about it but sadly the first people to
be damaged by Republicans succeeding as
you point out are going to
disproportionately be Republican voters
now what we do with this information
what you and your wife personally do I
don't really know
yeah we just recently had uh I forget
what the bill was is uh the abortion ban
at 12 weeks uh which lumped into there
was transgender affirming care yeah uh
for anyone under I think 19 but then
they also voted on the same day for
permitless concealed carry right uh and
none of those were popular bills at all
we were protesting inside the capitol so
loudly that they had to stop
um
the debating inside the chambers but
they still passed it and that was you
know I have a few friends that have
trans kids and you know it's
kind of heavy right now in Nebraska so
everybody's just a little bit worried
thank you for your thoughts though I
appreciate that all right
appreciate the call thank you so much
yeah all right there he goes why don't
we go next to how about Tristan from Los
Angeles Tristan welcome to the program
oh hello hello I have a pretty
open-ended question for you uh just
finished watching succession and I was
wondering if you had any takeaways from
it if you've watched it at all no I
don't even think I have what is that
like a Showtime show or HBO
yeah it's an HBO it's sort of similar to
I guess uh like a Murdoch sort of rain
and the the patriarch is ending and then
handing his crown and it's sort of the
machinations of a large media
conglomerate
I don't have HBO and I haven't seen a
single episode I I my my uh TV show
consumption is really low these days
just because I'm so so busy but a lot of
people have said that it is a great
program but unfortunately I've not seen
it
yep took a little baby and everything
exactly now where are you from Australia
yep okay and you live in the U.S
yeah yeah what's that like what's the
what's the biggest cultural difference
you find in the U.S from Australia
positive or negative either
I don't know I think well how about
positive first
um
there's less of a tall poppy syndrome
here but to me in Australia sometimes it
can feel like
if you try and do something different
people will try and bring you back into
the fold keep every keep that field of
poppies the same height
um but it I think it's guns it's just
it's so normalized here and I could be
talking with very liberal people and
next thing you know like oh yeah we're
gonna go shoot shotguns which is not
negative or positive it's just
incredibly different yeah and in in
Australia is that extremely uh extremely
rare since the laws have been changed
around owning weapons
yeah
yeah it
I I knew a kid who grew up on a farm
who'd shot guns but that's like
literally the only person I knew you
knew one person with guns yeah no that's
definitely very different that is that
is definitely different
yeah I'll have a think about it if I
call back all uh I'll uh maybe have a
more rounded answer for you all right
Tristan from Los Angeles I appreciate
the call
yeah thanks for having me all right
there he goes very powerful stuff let's
go to Kenny from Long Island Kenny
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today what can I do for you
Kenny from Long Island don't be the
first to drop you've got to accept my
invitation sir
oh boy
all right well that's too bad Kenny from
Long Island we are not going to hear
from today let's go to Gerald from Miami
now is that Miami Florida or Miami Ohio
Gerald please unmute so you can answer
my trivia questions
oh boy Gerald you're muting yourself
you've got to unmute yourself to be able
to talk to me can you hear me yes now I
can
oh hi uh
that's true General's from Miami Florida
great what's on your mind
oh yeah um I was just curious about you
know there's been a lot of uh talk
recently about uh upcoming like
Republican candidates you know that are
all jumping into the race for 2024 and I
know Biden has announced that he would
be running
um but I was curious if you had thought
about any other potential like
Democratic nominees that you know would
have a shot if they were to jump in the
race I don't think any would have a shot
really yeah I mean listen this if this
were an Open Primary here's the thing
people need to understand
I I support people challenging Joe Biden
I would like there to be debates on the
Democratic side if people credibly
challenge Joe Biden and are polling at
least you know some number eight percent
or something which right now I think
means at minimum you would have debates
between Biden and uh Bobby Kennedy Jr I
don't know where Marianne Williamson is
polling but I'm I'm in favor of debates
I'm in favor of a contested primary I
want people to run but if you're asking
me given what is going on and the fact
that the DNC is not incentivized to have
someone challenge the incumbent
president and that there's not going to
be a real primary I don't think there's
anyone who would have a shot I mean if
if we picked someone within with Mass
public appeal like I don't know if
Dwayne The Rock Johnson announced would
he be able to generate enough interest
because he's charismatic and whatever
that maybe he could actually defeat
Biden some I I just think that when you
have an incumbent president
the
um the odds that have to be overcome
because when you're an incumbent the DNC
is going to grease the wheels for you to
remain the nominee I don't know that
anybody could defeat Joe Biden given the
way that this primary is going to happen
ah I see yeah yeah it's just you know I
I've just been thinking I just
I just feel like you know with Joe
Biden's approval just kind of sinking I
just didn't know if he would uh
honestly I don't really think he could
actually win again to be honest with you
well listen I mean Biden's approval it's
not really sinking Biden's approval has
been steady since August of of last year
okay so that now is nine months where
it's just been in the low 40s when you
and I look at that we say oh that's
pretty low that means like high 50s
disapproves of the job Biden is doing
yeah that's the way it is with
presidents in the United States right
now the reality is that you can
absolutely get yourself re-elected with
a 43 approval rating we saw George W
bush do it you know it's it's not
Biden's approval is not the sign to me
that he's in trouble
ah okay all right well yeah I appreciate
it um thank you all right Gerald from
Miami uh great uh great question good to
hear from you why don't we go next to
oh I don't know how about
um how about Ryan from Dallas Texas Ryan
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hello David can you hear me yes I can
uh thank you for taking me um so I was
just wondering like you know you have a
lot of these extreme ideologies being
pushed by the right to stir up the group
of people on the left who don't follow
the news as much
um so they don't know the specific
details on certain topics for instance
like the um like the Dylan Mulvaney uh
saying
they were saying that uh he came out or
she came out you know the saying that
she was a spokesperson for Tamp for
tampons or something like that and it
was just like that wasn't even what
happened apparently she had said that
she kept one on her sometimes or
whatever you know for a friend or
whoever may need it or whatever and so I
just sometimes it's difficult because I
have friends who you know are on the
left but they they don't actually follow
the news like I had a friend who
mentioned that oh Kamala Harris hasn't
been you know in the public since she
came into office and so uh like she
hasn't been seen in public at all
yes and um even though you can follow
her on YouTube uh weekly and so I just I
don't know I just kind of wanted to hear
your thoughts on that yeah it's a pro I
have a lot of conversations with people
where they uh they they'll say things
like listen you know I grew up in a
democratic family but like this woke
stuff it's really got to end and I'll go
oh okay like what do you mean they go no
it's just you know it's crazy what's
happening with with uh with antifa and
it's just crazy it's like everything's
so woke you can't do anything anymore I
go oh like what what can't you do
they're gonna it's just it's like it's
just the it's the environment it's the
feeling of like you just can't
everything you say you're gonna get in
trouble for nobody oh like what is it
you're trying to say that you think
you'll get in trouble for well no it's
not me but like you know and you'll
spend 10 minutes like this and it goes
nowhere it goes nowhere and it's still I
guess someone who's voting for Biden or
whatever but it is kind of disappointing
yes and and I'm actually kind of worried
um because although um I think that
Bonnie has done uh I would say a decent
job as president I think that
um him being 80 um and running for
president again I think he's only doing
it just so that he can defeat Trump
because maybe you know the Democratic
party are afraid of trump winning but I
don't think that um Biden running at
this eight at his age is actually going
to be uh good for the Democratic party
as far as interest no I don't think it's
gonna it's it's not inspiring it doesn't
generate uh it doesn't generate interest
in the way that uh you're you're sort of
talking about I I agree with you
completely and you know so there are
people who write to me and go David I
don't know that Biden can defeat Trump
if you look at polling if Biden can't I
don't know that anyone else in
particular can either I mean Trump has a
significant level of support in this
country as shocking as that may be I
don't know who can beat Trump
yes and I have one last quick question
um I know previously you had mentioned
that you weren't a Democrat but I saw in
your video the other day you mentioned
you were a progressive Social Democrat
so I was just trying to confirm which
which it was so Social Democrat the D is
lower case it's not a party affiliation
so I'm not a capital D Democrat I'm not
a member of the democratic party I don't
um I'm not a I'm an independent voter
from a party affiliation standpoint
Progressive social democracy is an
ideology not a party so the D is lower
case you know what I'm saying yes yes
yes I think that is basically the the
clearest explanation
that'll help me for my next conversation
with my friends so thank you all right
Ryan thanks for the call
all right there goes Ryan let's go um I
mean against my better judgment let's go
to Donald from Palm Beach Florida I'm a
little worried about this
uh Donald from Palm Beach Florida you're
on the air
okay Donald from Palm Beach Florida uh
clearly it was a joke they bailed very
very funny joke let's go next to
um actually let's try once more Donald
from Palm Beach did you are you actually
trying to get on what's going on you're
not getting afraid now whatever joke you
were gonna do
yeah they are all right uh well
they're gone
how about uh let's go to Louis from New
Brunswick Louis from New Brunswick
welcome to the program
thank you Dave it's so good to be on
your program pleasure uh I just want to
jump in on something that the the last
guy was saying Ryan sure I was I I
noticed as well that people were
throwing around the word woke quite a
bit uh at work and just just around and
I realized that it meant vastly
different things to different people so
I started asking people
can you just help me understand what
that word means right and I was being a
little facetious and like I noticed like
the older generation talked about like
being hyper uh hypersensitive take you
know taking offense and it was like you
know pejorative like oh I don't like
woke like it's going woke all over the
place I asked young people uh especially
people especially like um people who
might identify as being a minority
um and they were like no it actually has
a lot to do with just understanding the
historical context of of you know of
historical wrongs and uh so I think
there's a huge problem I think that the
right really weaponized the words so
it's almost uh you know it's like a bad
word in a sense I'd go further I mean so
first of all Louis I have a YouTube clip
called something along the lines of they
don't even know what woke means where I
talk about a lot of this stuff in detail
I would go further than to say that
they've weaponized the word woke the
right has actually perverted the word
woke because really what woke originally
meant when the left used it seriously
now it's pretty facetiously used but
when the left use the word woke
what was meant was I'm aware of problems
in society some of which are more
structural than about the individual and
I would like to find solutions to those
problems like that that's that was
really the meaning of woke when it was a
sincere term and it's been weaponized
and perverted from the right by the
right I don't really know anyone
seriously using it like sometimes I'll
joke around like friends will say to me
someone will recommend the TV show for
example or a movie and then someone else
in the conversation will describe the
plot and someone will say sort of
tongue-in-cheek ooh sounds like it might
be a little too woke for me and it's a
joke you know everybody the term has now
become one that I don't know of people
on the left actually using in a serious
way
interesting yeah because the right
definitely uses it in a serious way I
got another question for you
um a couple months ago you had one of my
favorite authors Jefferson Morley on the
program wondering if you're gonna be
able to bring them back anytime soon
well you know we don't tend to have
authors on more than like once a year
but I'm glad to have them on again in
the future for sure
he does a great subsequent he talks you
know primarily about investigating
um the JFK assassination he's really up
to date on on um on disclosure coming
from the the government okay so I got a
question today uh NASA actually held a
public forum on their investigations of
UAP so like I guess that's like the
modern word for UFOs yeah
so here's my question to you uh
Jefferson Morley would pause and I think
a lot of people agree that there's still
a lot of uh disclosure that hasn't
happened in terms of the JFK
assassination case
now there's a lot of stuff going on in
the uh in like mainstream media like
from NASA today about UFO disclosure so
here's my question do you feel like this
is uh is this like a an endemic issue in
our in our modern society where there's
a lot of information that's being
withheld from the public
I don't know that it's a particularly
modern issue there's a long history of
the classification of documents there
are entire books written about whether
there is over classification I did an
interview about it I don't believe it's
specific or conspiratorial to uaps and
Kennedy as what I would say but there
are other people who have far more to
say about that issue than I do
so um David during the lockdown period
my wife and I really enjoyed watching
your show on YouTube live it was it was
almost therapeutic so I just want to say
thank you you're doing a great job
thanks for taking my call Louis thank
you so much very much appreciate that
that will do it for live calls today
we'll do more calls don't worry we'll do
it again we'll take a quick break and be
back with much more on the Friday show
right after this
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's hear from you it's time for the
Friday feedback of the week or the
Friday Feed Bag someone said it should
be called the Apple bags but that seems
a little risque for our particular
setting and audience so it is what it is
but let's start with a very important
message from John McCullough who said on
YouTube David pakman drinks Bud Light
and it shows I'm gonna tell you the
funniest thing about this whole Bud
Light thing now for some of you who
don't know Bud Light is now being
subjected to a boycott attempt by the
very people who say you shouldn't do
boycotts because it's a form of
cancellation Bud Light did a partnership
with Dylan Mulvaney Dylan Mulvaney is a
trans woman who I had never heard of
until conservatives got all angry about
her I don't even know whether we would
know who Dylan Mulvaney is were it not
for right Wingers who are Furious so
after Bud Light did this partnership
with Dylan Mulvaney many on the right
said we now have to boycott Bud Light
now here's the funny thing I've been
boycotting Bud Light since I started
drinking alcohol because I think Bud
Light is terrible I think it's just
disgusting completely disgusting give me
an Allagash White give me a Belgian
wheat give me come on guys please but I
think Bud light's disgusting so when
this entire thing happened I was able to
take the position that I will continue
not having Bud Light for no reason other
than I think it's absolutely disgusting
and terrible beer the funny thing is the
following before the Dylan Mulvaney
thing
when someone like me would say uh Bud
Light is terrible get me a micro brew
get me whatever
the right Wingers would go oh you
drink an American beer drink Bud drink
Coors drink whatever
now those very same people say Bud Light
is the one that's for the sissies who
support the the trans people or whatever
the case may be uh I have not had a Bud
Light in decades I continue not to drink
Bud Light but it is laughable that that
now counts as an insult but it just
reminds you about the strange bedfellows
and enemies that politics makes when
your brain can be so easily broken
alright another comment from kbj about
the economy kbj says to me how's Biden
working out for you bud I'm sure prices
of everything are down and the economy
is perfect right well I mean let's talk
it through Biden's working out fine for
me but I don't really need anything at
this point from the government
um the question is what does the economy
look like prices
when you look at inflation inflation
numbers are down down dramatically from
where they were a year ago so inflation
is slowing down significantly the
economy is never perfect we still have
an equality we have people who have to
work multiple jobs just like we did
under Trump and just like we did under
you know pretty it's not unique under
Obama we had that Obama under George W
bush Etc but it's hard to find
indicators that look particularly bad
the stock market is like pretty okay
unemployment is at record lows job
creation is doing well inflation's
coming down consumer confidence is doing
well a GDP has been on the upswing you
tell me I mean like point to the
indicators tell me the metrics that show
us that everything is terrible
Flawless P wrote in about book bands and
says so when told not to teach from the
Bible as though it were fact is not
teacher being censored unfairly
are you Banning books
LMAO your argument is cringe and useless
of course some topics and framing of
some topics topics aren't appropriate
for public schools that's not
controversial
I have to admit
I have no idea whether this person is in
favor or against the book Banning that
we're seeing in Florida I can't tell
they say something about the Bible when
told not to teach from the Bible as
though it were fact is a teacher being
censored unfairly
is that banning a book no oh I see the
point listen there's two different
things here
saying that religious texts have no
place in science class is not Banning
books it's saying this is a science
class and religious texts of any kind
have no place here it could be the Quran
it could be the Bible it could be
whatever scientologists read or believe
in or you know the golden tablets of
Joseph Smith it that's not Banning books
it's saying those books should be in
courses about comparative religion or
history of religion this is a very
confused person who as often is the case
is taking really strong positions about
things they don't understand even
remotely and that's really the tragedy
good looking man
Rodin
commented on YouTube
and it I guess is trying to make a point
about the the tendency towards violence
of people based on whether they're
left-wing or right-wing good looking man
says wear a Maga hat through New York
City and see how far you get before you
get canceled now where it's the wrong
where where and I love Biden hat through
Florida and you'll find that you'll be
perfectly safe you know
I have been places in New York City
where some clown comes through with a
Maga hat no one pays attention to them
to him I should say I've only ever seen
guys do it it the the funny thing about
this is this person wants us to believe
that in Florida with an Isle of Biden
hat you're fine you're safe but if you
wear a Maga hat in New York City you'll
get quote canceled but he's using that
in quotes to suggest almost like it's
going to be violence you won't be safe
I've been at bars I've been at outdoor
Terraces I've been in different places
where there's a dude usually between 22
and 28 years old wearing a Maga hat and
looking super pleased with himself like
he's doing something extraordinarily
clever no one pays attention to him I
was at a bar the bartender looked at the
Hat said nothing a guy ordered a drink
uh
the drink was made it was almost like
the the people I see with the Maga hats
in New York City
they almost seem underwhelmed that
nobody is reacting to them now can you
find instances of someone with a Maga
hat or someone with a Biden hat being uh
aggrieved I'm sure you can but the idea
that you're particularly unsafe in New
York City with a Maga hat give me a
break these people live in a fantasy
world it's just pathetic
um Echo icon says bless your heart you
look like you've been vaccinated how can
you tell is it that I'm functioning this
is the sort of bottom of the barrel
stuff but I look like I've been
vaccinated that's the new by the way the
the new sort of like alpha male sort of
thing getting vaccinated means you're
afraid to deal with the illness yourself
and you're caught it's sort of like
calling for your mommy this is the
dumbest analogy to vaccination that I've
maybe maybe ever heard but there's a lot
of dumb people here hey this is cool
Rosie O'Donnell yes that Rosie O'Donnell
who has actually been a follower of the
David Pacman show for a long time friend
of the show Rosie O'Donnell would love
to appear on her podcast if she's
interested
um commenting about Dianne Feinstein
and says about Dianne Feinstein sad
someone tell her it's time to bow out
with gratitude with gratitude so there
is Rosie O'Donnell with a very powerful
declaration we hear from her often
actually it's a beautiful thing all
right a couple comments from Facebook
Hubert Wisniewski says even if
Republicans do choose DeSantis as their
candidate Donald will still run for
president he still has to he has no
choice because he's hoping that saves
him from going to jail
my hope I am not a Praying person
but after my prayers were recently
answered for there to be Tech glitches
during Ron desantis's campaign launch I
now am like wow maybe prayer does work
so I think now I have to shift my prayer
to hoping that somehow de sanctimonious
Ron de sanctimonious that hopefully he
does win the Republican primary and that
Trump runs third party because it will
be the end of Republican chances in 2024
as we know them I hope Hubert is correct
about that
and then Eric Johnson Eric Johnson
commented on Facebook's says I think
these fines slash penalties need to
immediately be put in some escrow or
whatever kind of account so Trump can't
hide it spend it whatever while all
appeals are exhausted until the money is
actually taken away from trump it won't
be real to him I agree with this this is
in reference to the five million dollars
that failed former president Trump has
been ordered to pay Eugene Carroll
because he was found liable for both
sexual assault and defamation against
her and Trump was ordered to pay five
million dollars he's appealing it and so
what Eric is correctly pointing out and
it's something many of us have discussed
sure Trump's been ordered to pay but
until he pays we shouldn't assume that e
Gene Carroll is going to see even a
dollar of that money I believe it would
be great to sequester that money escrow
it immediately I have no belief that
that is actually what's happening and at
this point I certainly can't tell you
that I'm confident that Donald Trump is
actually going to pay out I hope he does
I hope Eugene Carroll's lawyers are
ready to do what needs to be done to get
that money
but I am until I see the money
I am going to be skeptical that it is
coming all right you can email info
davidpackman.com you can make a comment
on YouTube Facebook who knows what's
going to show up in the Friday feedback
segment and of course remember that
everything we do is supported so
strongly so directly by people like you
who go to joinpakman.com and they get
themselves a beautiful membership thank
your lucky stars every day you're not
Dave Pacman you don't have to be me
to get a membership and get access to
the bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com
bonus show is coming up right after this
otherwise I'll see you back here on
Monday
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors it's good to wear
sunscreen year round but it is really
the time of year for sunscreen right now
you may have heard FDA warnings about
chemical sunscreens which can cause skin
irritation and other issues that's why
it's best to use a mineral sunscreen
like the one by Ginger armor it is just
as effective much safer and you'll save
15 with the code Pacman the link is down
below